kaya gerber and cara de levine are each
other's
soulmates and they got matching tattoos
to prove it
yeah it's amazing on wednesday kaya
shared a birthday tribute to cara on her
insta story sharing this pic of their
feet writing happy birthday to my soul
mate
it's like they're holding hands but it's
their feet and instead of interlaced
fingers
it's their toes whatever floats your
boat anyway
the 18 year old model also shared this
pic of their matching
ink yep right there on the arch of their
feet
the word soulmate with soul
intentionally misspelled like soul of
their foot instead of
the usual soul you get the picture
the birthday tribute also included this
pic of cara wearing a sweatshirt with
well kaya's face all over it guys get
you a bestie like kara
she's the ultimate hype woman the models
have been spending
a lot of time together lately
everything's good i'm happy
in june kaya and kara were spotted
having dinner together in malibu with
kaya's famous parents
cindy crawford and randy gerber
they were also seen together at a black
lives matter protest
they showed the world their huge taylor
swift fans
posing together in the same cardigan and
clearly the pals that sweat together
stay together
seriously i am here for this dynamic duo
that does it all i'm so happy it's so
sweet
and speaking of t swift when eti caught
up with kara in 2019
she praised the singer for being a tough
cookie
she's just relentless endless fire
and and doesn't ever it's not biting to
to draw blood but biting when you need
to bite